you know the diversity agenda so-called
always amuses me in in in this in in
regard to the BBC because okay I'd like
to see diversity at the BBC
I really would I think it would be a
huge advance if we had proper diversity
at the BBC some political diversity for
instance and maybe some diversity from
the current monoculture of social
liberalism and a few social
conservatives that would be a kind of
diversity would it not hello and welcome
to trigonometry I'm Frances foster i'm
konstantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you're bored with people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about a trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts are brilliant guests
this week is a former BBC journalist an
executive Robin akin welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much well
for anyone who doesn't know you will get
into the couple of books you've written
about bias of the BBC tell us a little
bit about how are you in this chair
today what's been your journey through
life and how have you come to you know
be talking about the issues we'll be
talking about today um yes well I'm a
journalist and have been for 40 years
and more
so my Kant journey through journalism if
you like was a bit of a march back in
time in the days that I started I
started out on a local newspaper that my
pre story was that I was a medical
student and so I started out at Medical
School and I was lazy and feckless and
the Dean of the medical school had me in
and said mr. Aiken you have been
outstandingly
idle and we can do without you so I left
and I became a journalist there's only
really two options from that point
journalist to become a comedian yeah
absolutely I discovered actually that
that idleness is not a not an advantage
Infantino it's a hard-working
professional when you get into it but I
started and because of this rather rocky
start I started a bottom on a local
newspaper in Walsall in the West
Midlands the black country although I
come from Somerset I was brought up in
Somerset and so that was a real
education for me because the black
country is a real working-class area and
I had been brought up in bath and in
Somerset in a middle-class environment
so I learned an awful lot through that
by various stages I made my way first of
all for local radio for the BBC and then
I was appointed to a reporting job in
Scotland and I was the economics and
business correspondent for BBC Scotland
for some years in the middle of the
1980s and after that I moved down to
London I came down to work for BBC News
so I was working on the main news
outlets what we used to call the
firemen's service so you were sort of
sitting there on the taxi rank and
whatever came up you went and did it
involved a fair bit of travel and you
got to do you know everything from air
crashes to I can't think of a suitable
BBC wasn't really into that but you know
I get everything anything in anything
and then I went to the money program and
I worked there for a few years and then
a program called on the record which the
politics program and then it did a bit
of news again and eventually I was hired
by The Today programme and Rod little
was the editor in those days and he
hiked me out of obscurity put me on the
Today programme and those were my best
years as a reporter really it's a
strange dystopian kind of unrecognizable
world that you describe where Rod little
could be on the Today programme I don't
imagine that happening today which I
suppose is the subject what we're really
talking about so you're a conservative
as I understand yeah and you've worked
your way through the BBC and your books
are essentially your reflections on
being a conservative at the BBC what is
that like
okay well let me just explain something
to your constant down now I am a
conservative that is true and and I'm a
conservative social conservative I would
say well and I make the distinction
because I think that social conservative
values of one are the ones that matter
most to me and they are the ones which
are most neglected and most
discriminated against by the BBC I also
happen to be and have been in the past a
supporter of the Conservative Party
itself so I'm a conservative in both in
both senses in in those terms but what
matters most to me is social
conservative what was it like at being
at the BBC it was like being the only
black guy in a crowd of white men so
when I was at the BBC I've always been
interested in politics and I always used
to quiz my colleagues about their
political affiliations and it became
very clear to me from an early stage in
my BBC career that I was surrounded by
left wingers in short what we were were
Liberal Democrats or they were sort of
they thought of themselves as centrists
but essentially they were on the left or
slightly on the Left center-left it
became particularly apparent during the
Thatcher years because snatcher was such
a divisive figure and I had as I said I
worked as an economics correspondent and
it became clear to me that the in purely
economic terms the way we were running
the country in the 1970s where we had
large hugely loss-making nationalized
industries this was a foolish way to run
our economy because what we ended up
doing was putting a lot of money into
industries which were increasingly
uncompetitive and if you take Adam Smith
the great economist and his Wealth of
Nations the idea that the simple idea
boils down to this that there's some
called competitive advantage so Iceland
um has a competitive advantage in
producing fish Germany does not why is
that well
Iceland's in middle the ocean as long as
a trawler meant Germany's the middle
Europe and doesn't so you let alertly
you let Iceland produce the fish Germany
produced the cars right in our case in
Britain we were very good at some things
and still are very good at some things
for instance we're very good at many of
the service industries like architecture
marketing advertising banking these big
service industries we're excellent of us
in fact we're world beaters we're not so
good as it happens at making steel and
there are reasons for that built-in
reasons why we're not particularly
competitive when it comes to steelmaking
Thatcher realized that and her whole
economic thrust was to move money away
from these loss-making industries free
them up sell them off see how they could
do in the free market and allow the
wealth of our nation to be put into more
productive and more productive ends but
the consequence of that social
consequence of that was hugely
disruptive and very divisive people lost
their jobs it was absolutely awful for
many people and the human pain and
misery which resulted from that
shouldn't be underestimated but I took
the view that this was a necessary form
of shock treatment to get the country's
economy back on track within the BBC you
could count on one hand the number of
people who thought like that I found
myself in the position often of working
on programs where they were quite
explicitly hostile to - Thatcher and and
this hostility was an ideological
hostility to what Thatcher herself was
doing although she won three big
election victories and was obviously
popular people understood in the country
what she was doing the BBC almost became
the official opposition during that time
so I found myself as a conservative in
BBC somebody who was politically
friendless although I have many friends
and at the BBC know they're great people
to work with you know there're that
people like you know they're well
educated they're decent polite people
but they overwhelmingly come from
liberal social backgrounds and they
overwhelmingly inclined to the left now
I suppose a counter-argument to that is
this whenever I look at you know there's
a Labour forum on Facebook great people
you know anyway um
all I see from the Labour forms are
brexit Broadcasting Corporation why is
Faraj on there all the time you know the
BBC is right-wing it's a cabal is it not
the fact that as the BBC you know they
forgot to put on left and right they're
gonna take a pummeling from both sides
um well funny enough actually what you
say Francis is is exactly the BBC the
argument the argument the BBC itself
uses to justify its own its own stunts
it says well look we're criticized from
both sides therefore we must be right
however I don't know if if either of you
saw did either of you see the interview
between a chap called ben shapiro and
andrew yeah yes we okay so and i thought
that was a very telling interview and
the reason I thought it was telling was
was this that Andrew Neil is the BBC's
in-house right winger he's widely
recognized I think you'd agree people
see him as a very right-wing
personalities right but and that
interview went off the rails because
Andrew Neil started a line of
questioning about the abortion debate in
the US and he said he used the words he
used was he said he said yes but the you
know some of the laws being introduced
in some of the states are taking us back
to the dark ages
these are barbaric
laws and he was talking about
restrictive abortion laws in the US and
Shapiro who is of course a right winger
in American terms is a social
conservative and he immediately bridled
that he said he said you know it he said
- he said 200 and he said are you a
comment journalist or a you an objective
journalist the point being that he was
the point he was making was that Andrew
Neil had included in the question a very
loaded comment that was that these laws
which were trying to restrict abortion
were taking us back to the dark ages
what that showed to me was this that the
BBC's most notable most clearly
right-wing journalist is actually a
social liberal when it comes down to it
he's on the side of the social liberal
argument the social liberal argument
which says that we are we we are liberal
about issues like abortion divorce
euthanasia sexual moral conduct in
general we don't care what you're doing
your bedrooms you can do whatever you
want in your bedrooms and that's no
concern of ours we approve it you can
worship whoever you like we don't care
about that we don't think it matters and
this is the social liberal position this
is actually what one of your previous
guests on this show
Sir John Curtis is exactly what he was
saying which is that the dividing line
now in the brexit debate is between not
between left and right it's between
social conservatives and social liberals
the point I'm trying to make to you is
that yes the BBC gets criticized from
the left but underlying it the BBC's
stance is solidly socially liberal in
fact it has no as far as I know and I
believe me I I keep a close eye on it
there are no what I would call social
conservative voices on the BBC
fact they don't invite on for interview
social conservatives so the things which
concern me as a social conservative not
subjects for debate on the BBC let me
give me an example you tell me for
instance that you were a teacher in an
Eastern school a deprived Eastern London
School right and you were accounted an
anecdote about a child who came from a
troubled background one of the biggest
problems and facing the country I think
in a social sense is the breakdown of
family life and and the state can do
many things but it cannot act as a
substitute for proper parents if you're
a boy and you're brought up without a
father the consequences of that can be
dramatically bad because you have no
proper role model you might have a mum
who loves you and I'm not knocking
single mums some of whom I know do a
fantastic job self-denying
job to raise their kids but if you don't
have a stable male figure with the mum
over a long period of time you have bad
consequences now that debate which i
think is is underpinned so many of the
other debates which are picked up
endlessly about the BBC for instance how
many times have you heard on the BBC
people agonizing about the crisis in
mental health amongst young people the
crisis in mental health among young
people is inseparable from the breakdown
of family life because mental disorders
in young people are very often the
result always but very often the result
of family breakdown we've had people
want to talk about this on this show so
we're doing the job the BBC is not doing
but to come back to your point about
getting height from left wingers we get
hate from right wingers to every time we
every time we talk to anybody about
anything to do with Tommy Robinson we
just get this massive wall of hay or how
we are Kuck and it starts there
happening now the right now is what
tell me Robin that's what's happening so
we get a lot of that but my point to you
by Andrew Neal a counterpoint might be I
personally agree with you I think the
BBC seems to me as a socially liberally
dominated institution but Andrew Neil
has eviscerated people like Owen Jones
and Munroe Bergdorf and Kant living some
beautifully right so you could argue
that the reason that he was putting that
point to ben shapiro isn't that that is
his point of view is that the style of
interview that Andrew Neil does is to
put the opposite side of the point of
view that he's challenging in the strong
and sometimes emotive terms as possible
in order to I mean let's be honest
create clickbait sure and you make a
very good point that Neil is a hostile
interviewer and a very good interview
yeah I mean I would say he's probably
the most effective it
he's the the most effective effective
interrogator the BBC has on the front
line however and the reason that
interview the one with Shapiro you know
we're talking about it now because it
made it there was a bit of pickup in the
press because it was seen as a bit of a
car crash car crash interviews reveals
something usually not about the
interviewee but about the interviewer
you think of Kathy Newman yeah that's
exactly right
okay so there you heard so the point of
these interviews supposedly is to is to
put the interviewee on the spot if the
interviewer shows their cards and
becomes instead of being the
interrogator becomes a protagonist in
the debate lets their own opinions as it
were go up against those of the
interviewee not in the formula of some
people would say or you know some people
might think but as Andrew Neil now in
that interview he didn't preface his
remarks with some people might think he
had he said but these is it but these
laws are taking us back to the dark ages
that's with his words right it was quite
clear after I mean no one after an
interview I thought well I didn't learn
a lot about jaw I didn't learn very much
about Ben Shapiro's views oh nothing I
couldn't a guest I learned something
about Andrew Neil's views I actually
tweeted about this that I thought they
both came out of it badly in a way I I
and actually I say they both we all came
out of it badly because you watched an
interview with somebody for 16 minutes
and you're nothing about them if you
hadn't known who Ben Shapiro was before
then you've learnt almost nothing about
what are their point of views why is he
so incredibly popular in America what is
it that he's saying what is his view on
Donald Trump which is quite nuanced and
and not just massively Pro time so you
spent 16 minutes of your life yeah
listening to something yes that tells
you nothing about the person to whom you
just listen it see the for me the
difference between the Kathy Newman
interview and the Andrew Neil is I think
it actually did show something about
Shapiro and I think it was an inability
to cope under pressure and the moment we
had a direct question because Shapiro
likes to portray himself as someone who
goes up against students and essentially
truth bullets and all the rest of it but
when he came up as somebody who was at
the similar level I don't think he could
cope under pressure that was the
impression that I got from it well I'd
agree with that actually and I'm in fact
I I agree with both of you I think they
were both losers innocence I and I I do
think that Shapiro to me came across as
a very brittle rather thin-skinned
individual and he couldn't cope with
Andrew Neil's gravitas I mean you know
Neil's he is a really serious journalist
you know he has held all these positions
you know he's been the editor of The
Sunday Times and times you know he heads
up the what I'm saying is here's a
seasoned journalist be good at what he
does he's bloody good at what he does to
me shapiro looked a light-weight sort of
he looked young and
I was scared I mean didn't handle it at
all well and but also I didn't I didn't
I would like to have known what it was
about Shapiro that as you say made him
why is he popular why does anybody you
know why was Andrew Neil bothering to
interview this guy Shapiro because he's
got this huge following in the states
why what is it that he's saying we never
got to that point no because we got
sidetracked into all this kind of into
this battle between the two of them
which was I would say to Francis as well
Ben Shapiro I think came out of a badly
because she didn't know her and Rinna
was and he was unprepared you go the the
reason Ben Shapiro is as big as he is
you go and watch him being interviewed
by Piers Morgan while Piers Morgan was
doing his American show on gun control
which is a very difficult issue and he
he he comes across as very very calm and
measured but also very strong so it it's
an issue where everybody did badly I
think we all came out of it very badly I
mean I think a more prescient interview
and I know this will go out when this
goes out you know the European elections
will be done and dusted but Andrew Mars
interviewer Faraj I thought was a
disgrace and I'm not probably brexit and
I was watching this going why are you
not addressing about brexit why are you
talking about that's absolutely five ten
whatever years ago I could not agree
with you more
I thought at ten you okay a lot of
people don't know the mechanism of these
things I do and I know what happens
right you've got a big political
interview on a show like the marché that
is thoroughly prepared for so the
production team in a first of all they
learned their man midweek and then they
have a few days and as some usually
bright young junior producer who who
puts together a brief and the brief is
presented to to tomorrow so he knows
everything that you might care to know
you know often that with the little
embarrassing quotes or little gaffes
that the guy has made and then the Maher
and the editor senior producer types
would sit around there and then they try
to plan an interview right so this is
this is how we're gonna play it
start on this and then at this point you
know we'll use we'll start quizzing him
about these things which is supposedly
embarrassing now um I think I was the
wrong game plan because we're not
electing a prime minister you know we're
not electing a prime minister in these
euro elections however well Faraj does
he's not going to be walking in the
gates of number two it by the time they
century comes out you never know maybe
already there you know I mean you know
basically the thing is so all this stuff
that math through it through it Faraj
did he say this about the NHS Diddy's
what about the poster these were
irrelevant issues as Faraj rightly
pointed out as far as kept trying to
bring the thing back on track and st.
but you know and you're ignoring what
the issue is here and I do think that
Faraj is right when he made the issue of
democratic accountability the central
thing he wanted to talk about because
that is certainly one of the big issues
the big issue really in in these
elections which are now a few days away
from us but by the time you see this
will be done and dusted and I suspect we
know how that's that's gonna turn out
guys
we wanted to take a moment to say thank
you to every single one of you that has
supported us on patreon subscribe start
that sent us money through PayPal we
could not do the show without you please
keep supporting us and if you haven't
already please consider doing so because
that is exactly what allows us to keep
improving the show every single week
having said that we've now also got a
corporate sponsor to sell out to indeed
we have and it is the magazine the week
and what the week does is it pulls
together the best articles from over 200
different sources from publications such
as a Times The Telegraph or for our one
liberal snowflake fan The Guardian they
do exactly what we do on the show which
is pulled together balanced opinions
from different sides so that you can
make your own mind up and you don't get
stuck in an echo chamber and if you want
to take advantage of this special offer
all you need to do is go to the week dot
Cote dot uk'
slash offer use our special code trigger
and
we'll get six free issues of the week
the great thing about the week is that
allows you to read less and know more
which is gonna appeal to people like
Frances who can barely read and it's not
just news the week also brings you the
latest from the world of sports so if
you want to find out what's going on in
the transfer window who mentor United
are going to sign the week will also
deliver you the latest freshest news on
that which one appeal to someone like
Constantine because he's a massive
virgin grown back man anyway guys
seriously we know that you've got busy
lives we understand that you're not
going to be reading 200 articles a week
and that's what the magazine does it
brings together those articles in a one
combined easy package that you can read
and know what's going on join thousands
trust the week as their essential
curated new source try for yourself and
get your first six issues completely
free to take advantage of this great
offer visit the week code UK forward
slash offer enter our code which is of
course trigger and get your first six
issues completely but on the BBC just
carrying on one of the things Frances
and I were just we were talking on the
phone before this interview and just
talking about what's happened to the BBC
in general beyond the bias issue that
you talk about
I remember watching question time
religiously I remember watching Don
Jamar show religiously I obviously I'm
interested in politics I've been in the
audience of question time that's how
interested I wasn't it and I watched
question time probably for the first
time in a year a couple of weeks back
when Nigel Faraj was on it and they were
talking endlessly about brexit which is
an important issue and the only
conclusion I came away with is that we
must leave question time with no deal
good because it's just it's unwatchable
I couldn't agree more and it's not
because it's Faraj or someone else every
time I've tried to watch it in the last
year maybe watch a five minute clip I
just can't watch it know it's
unwatchable so what is happening
to an institution that I personally
think is very important yeah British
public life well you would get many BBC
people who would say and it would
acknowledge the fact that the question
time you know has been and still is in
some people's eyes one of the most
important political programmes of the
week so what's happened to it well um it
has become trivialized in in a certain
way I think I've stopped watching it
actually because I I find like you there
is something about it which no longer
does what it says on the tin so what you
want from a parrot or what I want from a
program like that is to see serious I
want to see the questions which are in
the mind of the public put two serious
people in politics and hear what their
responses are and I think that as a
format is a very respectable honorable
in fact a vital thing to do in a way but
somehow question time seems to have lost
the ability to do that properly I'm not
quite sure why actually maybe it's to do
with I know that they have their debt
you know that if you I know that um I
know someone actually who has worked on
question time as a no I does but and she
was telling me that how difficult it is
for them to balance the panel right you
know it's very difficult at a time when
politics seems to be fragmenting to get
every point of view so that's one
problem but also I think sometimes you
know I was started someone else on a
slightly different issue but I've
started to sell on a friend recently and
we were talking about and I was saying
you know something has happened in my
lifetime is that 3040 years ago no one
gave it
because about what actors thought about
politics right actors had their place
and they might be very engaging and good
at what they do but no gave a [ __ ] about
what they thought because because you
know actors spend their whole time
pretending to be somebody else what
credentials are those what what is it
about being an actor that qualifies you
to appear on question time to ask a
question to answer questions about
brexit well frankly the answer to that
is absolutely nothing but over the pier
over the course of the last thirty years
with the suraíhs of the celebrity
culture the we've all been sucked into
that and somehow suddenly you know what
Hollywood thinks matters and I think
that's one of the problems with with
with with with question time that so the
the the personnel if you like has been
somewhat watered-down
downgraded in a way they're no longer
and they're no longer quite serious
people that they should be but see this
is where I agree with you in theory but
I think in practice it's actually quite
often the other way around our good
friend Jeff Norco who we found on the
show who's a comedian every time he goes
on the he seems to be the lone voice of
reason yeah yeah you know what I mean
yeah and so what I'm talking about isn't
so much that they've watered down the
intellectual talent or whatever it's
just that it's it's a they're just
bickering yeah well that's so so well
that's a very interesting observation so
what does that really if they're just
bickering and that's very good that's
actually a very good description of what
you do see so that would tell you
wouldn't it that they're not arguing
about substantial issues what they're
doing is they're squabbling over they're
in their own little position they're
fighting their own little corner but
actually in a way all the politicians
are in somehow
they have more in common with each other
than they do with the rest of us but
actually you know the political classes
it were and it's bit I think this is
becoming clearer and clearer actually
because of the rather harsh light that
the brexit debate has shown on our
politics it's becoming clearer and
clearer that that that em that our
politicians and our the ruling class the
media class so you know the the
politicians the the senior journalists
the senior academics senior civil
servants they United they all share the
same view their almost on men their anti
brexit I mean you wouldn't have the
problem we've had with brexit where it
not for the very simple fact than the
hassle Commons you've got nearly 80
percent of MPs who are personally
opposed to brexit they voted to remain
as one factor in the House of Lords is
probably 95 percent so what you've got
is you've got a ruling class of
politicians who are sitting there on top
of the pile
running the mechanism which is supposed
to get us out but they all want to stay
in it's no great surprise that you know
we've ended up in the muddle we have and
I think maybe that's what's maybe that's
what's on showing in in question time
now they you know they're it's kind of
politicians against the people somewhere
do you think the BBC's engaged in a race
to the bottom because of social media
because everybody wants to see a
two-minute clip where so-and-so gets in
inverted commas destroyed or whatever
else so they feel that need to buy into
it hence the bickering
hence the talking over one of each other
hence you know the lack of listening oh
you an see if you could just destroy
France
what do I think about that I think well
I think that the there is an ineluctable
pressure to go down market in certain
respects
so the BBC is alerts publicly-funded of
course it fills pressure from commercial
rivals and so inevitably it has to
compete in the same market right in a
way it has it hasn't gone quite as low
as some of the other outlets for
instance I don't know if you ever watch
naked attraction so so so I hadn't seen
it but when I was writing when I was
researching the book I was thinking
about and you know the way in which for
instance now we can access pornography
right at the press of a button you can
see anything you want really you've led
a sheltered life yeah so anyway I am for
the first time I heard about naked
attraction I watched it and you know for
anyone who hasn't watched it basically
it's a it's a genital beautiful Beauty
parade right so you people they they
they stand there they hold their breaks
down and you get a look at either Willy
or Fannie and oh this one I like this
one I don't this one's a bit sort of
tattoo this one's a bit droopy this is
the point I'm making is that this I mean
you know can means that can't we go
lower than that I mean the point is if
that is you know that is trash culture
yes right I mean you know we like okay
well guys there in the room we're all
smirking right it's it you know and it's
you know wow you know Fanny is on the TV
yes great you know but
actually you know when you think about
it to be a man to be to stand up and be
a man and not to be led by your dick
your whole life to exercise some
self-restraint as best you can is a
lesson that every man needs to learn and
put into action
if you pander constantly to the sexual
urge in males a it's almost irresistible
for young males and for old males to I
mean look you know me I mean I'm not
dead yet but you know it's the sex drive
is immensely powerful and it can be
exploited for commercial reasons which
is what pornography does in my view
pornography exploits both women
sometimes not always but certainly men
because males are have this biological
imperative
we're fascinated by the subject we can't
resist images of the other sex and the
sex act itself and these things just are
immensely powerful drivers of male
behavior and if you allow that
unrestricted access to that you do
damage because I do think actually that
I mean I am naked attraction is an
example of a sort of creeping pauna
fication of television and some
mainstream uses it it's in its third or
fourth series now so and you know
actually funnily enough you know when it
first came on there were some complaints
to Ofcom the orbital regulator right so
people said you know this is indecent
show off gamma Idol look at it and they
said well actually we don't think it's
indecent because basically what this is
doing its just a variant on a dating
show and and because there's no actual
sexual contact it's fine well um forgive
me but I think that is really feeble
and a pathetic response from Ofcom
because but then Ofcom is entirely
staffed by social liberals who
presumably see nothing at all wrong with
a show like that whereas I think
actually that it's debasing and
degrading it degrades the culture it
degrades the individuals who are
involved in it it degrades the audience
for watching it and I think would be a
better happier healthier country now
what you've talked about with social
liberals do you not think that the
problem and the challenges that a lot of
these broadcasters face is that certain
types of people are attracted to certain
professions for example bankers yuju
you're naturally they're gonna be more
materialistic they're gonna be you know
less you could argue less socially
conscious they're gonna be more driven
because road to cocaine more prone to
cocaine absolutely all these sitting all
these things I mean there's stereotypes
but there's a reason that they exist yes
and you don't think that Sochi liberal
people are more attracted to being
journalists because a lot of people they
go into journalism that they have this
fantasy you know that they're going to
be the one bringing down you know this
evil corporation with a big scope and
the rest of it how do you bring a
corporation down to the news of the
world yeah that got to its name sorry it
was just a terrible pun yeah oh I just
don't ever do that again
a number of interesting points one is
you're absolutely right that journalists
play up to the mental image of the
journalist is hearing so you know
there's this long-standing tradition of
movies and television programs and books
where the journalist is the hero
character right you know he's the he's
the seeker after truth it brings down
the big corporation or whatever it is so
journalists are very attracted to that
as an idea but the the other point that
you make about isn't it the case that
bankers naturally know that a mercenary
instinct is the sort of select or is
that it is the reason why
people might go into banking and they
might not go into journalism but my
point is slightly different which is
that probably you would find you in fact
you would certainly find that the upper
reaches of the banking profession is
just as socially liberal as is as are
the upper echelons of the journalistic
profession there was a a sociologist by
the name of Peter Berger and he was very
prominent in the 1960s in in in America
and he he wrote a very influential book
about secularization theory and and what
he predicted was he said that by the
21st century so he was writing in 1968
death and called thereabouts here is a
very prominent piece in the New York
Times and it said that by the by the
21st century religious believers would
be restricted to isolated pockets
beleaguered in a sea of secular of a
secular world and he saw this as the
future of the world
this is 1968 right so in this Sun in the
succeeding 40 years you heard what you
heard the Iranian Revolution in the
ayatollahs kicking out the show you
heard the fall of the Soviet Union
precipitated let us remember by a sort
of by a Roman Catholic subversive
resistance in Poland which was the thing
which sparked the whole thing of if had
the rise of Islamic state you've had all
these phenomena phenomena and you've had
actually the reconversion of Russia back
into a a much more religious state than
it used to be so far from being far from
fulfilling Berger's prediction that the
world would become secularized in fact
religion has not gone away and in some
ways religion has become more prominent
in our world today than it was back in
the 1960s but now Berger is very very
interesting and very intelligent you
know he's someone well worth reading
actually but he so he had a long life
and in the
in the about ten years ago he thoroughly
recanted secularization theory he said I
got it wrong his new take is this he
says that secularization theory is is is
carried by a very select elite group of
Western people Western type people they
have some things in common they are all
very well educated they all come from
well-educated backgrounds and they
occupy senior positions in all those
professions and occupations which mold
our current reality so in the law in
government in the media you've got
people who basically subscribe to
secularization Theory they are
themselves secular they're not believers
they are atheistic and materialistic and
secular and but because of their
influential Pacifica's there in these
very influential jobs they of course
have a massively disproportionate
influence on the way the rest of us
think I've slightly lost my train of
thought
we're talking about why so why would so
- what I'm saying is that the is that is
that basically it's the same sort of
people you would find you would find
very similar attitudes at the in the
boardroom of goldman sachs as you would
in the boardroom at the BBC or in the
boardroom at channel 4 or in the
newsroom a channel 4 but I guess Francis
point is that when we talk about the BBC
being biased
yeah that's not because evil BBC
directors are hiring only people that
they agree with it's because what he's
saying I think is that you know
naturally attract a certain type of
person and therefore you get this
naturally created
actually occurring bias if you like
right um yeah I think there is certainly
I mean Oh There is obviously truth in
that because you know you didn't become
a journalist unless you like writing you
know it's all it's all you've got to be
able to write and you've got to be able
to think straight and you've got to be
like you don't have an intellectual
curiosity about the world I mean I I'd
say about you know in my own experience
um I went to some fascinating places did
some fascinating jobs but what ended up
fascinating me most was the organization
I was working for and I found it highly
resistant to the idea of any critical
analysis the BBC's
capability when it comes to self
examination I'm not great and and so but
of course so yes I mean it in one sense
of course you're right and and no one
who is enumerate goes into banking a
suspect and no one who is illiterate
goes into journalism so in that sense
you're absolutely right what the point
I'm making there is that in fact the the
elite in Western societies all share by
and large the same outlook on life
I was we were a conference last week and
I was talking to a particularly notable
academic from one of the best
universities not known in the UK in the
world and he was saying that he
cancelled his BBC subscription which
first of all blew my mind that you know
somebody would do it and I said why and
he said I don't like the way the BBC
reports on certain subjects on certain
topics in particular the Julie Jones and
he used that as an example and he said
that the BBC were ignoring that because
it did not fit with their political
outlook would you agree with that 100
percent 100 percent you know I think
it's deeply ironic the BBC keeps
reporting on this idea of fake news
right
so the BBC has made I mean the BBC has
made it absolutely plain that it hates
everything to do with Donald Trump
it can't stand the man can't stand his
platform and it and this shows through
in everything it reports about him
now the BBC picked up on this phrase
which originated with Trump or at least
he made it he made it he popularized
this phrase of fake news and he said you
know the the the mainstream media in the
US was full of fake news now what did he
mean by that
you see I think that this is the
critical distinction which people miss
things can be accurate news can be
accurate but still unfair so if I only
relay accurate but negative information
about you on my news program I'm being
accurate but you're not being fair you
know what I says so I was I was raised a
Catholic and the the good nuns who
raised me used to teach me about the
difference between calumny and
detraction right so calumny is when you
tell a lie about somebody detraction on
the other hand is when you tell a truth
about somebody but a truth which ought
not to be told so maybe private
information which is greatly to their
disadvantage the BBC is a great
detractor of Trump it doesn't it doesn't
lie about him what it does is it only
tells a negative side of the story the
Sheila Joan the flip side of that coin I
mean the Jillian of the French version
of that the Sheila Joan as I understand
it and I haven't he had minimal contact
with them personally and that was at a
road block in northern France
I found them absolutely charming this is
France you and I were discussing yes
well the fact that what when I look at
the BBC News website which is still the
place that I go to yeah to see some of
the news what I notice is not I don't
feel that the story
in Acura is just there clearly selected
to present a very particular view and
nowhere is that more true in my opinion
than the diversity agenda and one of the
things I wanted to ask you about is the
BBC now has policies in place to
increase the representation of certain
minority groups they have this I saw an
article the other day that the BBC want
to make sure that 1 out of 7 headline TV
presenters is gay or lesbian which made
me wonder why they want to reduce the
number of gay right so they've got this
again they'd seemed like to me in hiring
this positive discrimination in favor of
certain ethnic minorities and that seems
to me now in the world that we live in
to be part of a particular mindset mmm
that isn't just something that people do
just because that seems to be a
reflection of a particular view do you
think those things are connected I do
and you know the diversity agenda
so-called always amuses me in in ingress
in regard to the BBC because ok I'd like
to see diversity at the BBC I really
would
I think it would be a huge advance if we
had proper diversity at the BBC some
political diversity for instance and
maybe some diversity from the current
monoculture of social liberalism and a
few social conservatives that would be a
kind of diversity would it not I mean
the fact is that simply having a colour
chart you know color code chart and
making sure you've got every you know
the right proportion of everyone from
from black to Alvino and everything in
between and guarantee is nothing about
the fairness of the out of the output
all it means is that you have window
dressed the screen in some way which is
thought to reflect modern Britain
without doing anything to seriously
consider the content of what you're
broadcasting
which is surely the important thing you
know there is no diversity in the BBC in
that they in there in that sense they
are all social liberals as I really know
as we started going about Andrew Neil
the great right-wing yeah he's a social
liberal there are no social
conservatives at the BBC Robin wants his
job back how many I'll be no Derek and
there are the BBC I reckon there's
somebody here discussing it now is the
office we have no Albano's this needs to
change they want that go from The
DaVinci Code but but you see this a lot
in comedy and this is one of my bugbears
the majority of people in the referendum
voted brexit there is only one Pro
brexit comedian on the BBC it's Jeff and
all got we love you Jeff you're
brilliant
there should be other comedian of course
why is there not anymore well right when
he's out funny because that's what
people say as if as if being on
different sides of the political
spectrum somehow effects are funny yeah
well I mean oh you know there yeah so
why is that
okay let's it's a very interesting
question you know I've often I often
wondered why it was that Jeremy Hardy
r.i.p bless him who I didn't find funny
at all I thought he was merely a
propagandist um you could not imagine
someone the obverse of Jeremy Hardy on
the right ever been given a platform by
the BBC it just wouldn't happen when I
was wait I mean so um this comes down to
the idea of what is it work here is a
very pernicious and insidious way of
patrolling the reservation right within
the reservation certain things are
allowed we're all in the reservation and
the reservation is guarded by
a liberal elite which allows certain
things to be said but certain things are
not allowed to be said that's why I've
got mine in my book that the noble liar
and the idea behind the title of that
book is this that the BBC is not a
Millian organization motivated to do us
harm on the contrary it thinks of itself
as being a very good organisation
motivated by the best of intentions and
it wants to do is all good and that's
why it won't allow us to talk about
certain things which it doesn't feel a
proper to talk about because they're
nasty so for instance one might say that
the BBC has thrown its protective weight
behind the Muslim community in Britain
so anybody who attempts to critique
Islam is almost instantly labels as an
islamaphobe and the effect of that is to
crush all comment about Islam and to
bully those people who have genuine
concerns about Islam and and and the way
that it operates it's to bully them into
silence that's why you you don't hear
those debates on the BBC but there are
lots of other things they won't talk
about you know the limitations of
feminism Rob's decided to lighten the
mood
feminism his Russian is pricked up yes
we must talk about feminism excellent
tell me why women are inferior I just
like to say that was racist and Francis
is getting fired tomorrow I'm sorry well
you know I think that um that look my
generation of men British men I was born
in the 1950s and my generation of
British men rapidly came to the
conclusion that feminism was making
points which could not be refuted in it
there is no reason why women shouldn't
follow whatever career path they want
there is no reason why when they're in
that career they shouldn't be given
exactly the same opportunities as men
however I've got so many jokes in my
head I carry on Robin will have to strap
in he's gonna start foaming an ideology
which which a 90 so so feminism started
as a crusade and it started as a sort of
outsider crusade it's now become
mainstream and its beliefs have hardened
into an ideology which have the effect
of suborning the interests of others and
so you've got the paradoxical effect now
that that males young males particularly
a beginner and I have met some young men
who feel that the Dyson air loaded
against them in fact feminism has become
divisive and it is no recipe for for
harmony between the sexes that we have
this constant feminist crusade to
achieve yet more equality I mean I think
equality has already there are of course
you know pockets of resistance there
always will be but look the world isn't
fair and it never will be
you can't just wave the magic wand and
make things fair of course you can pass
laws which make things fairer but there
will always be instances of unfairness
what we have to strive for is not to
empower one particular section of the
community but to look at us all as you
know we're all human beings we all
deserve respect we all deserve our own
dignity we deserve to
to fulfill ourselves in the best way we
can of course all those things that are
absolutely true but feminism tamina
seems to be the it they're akin to
feminism to me looks like the soldier on
the backs of battlefield gain down
bayonetting the wounded right
so they vanquished the foe which was
male chauvinism but they can't kick the
habit of attacking men and maleness and
actually for all its apparent strengths
and you know that kind of macho stuff
you know underneath men are just as
vulnerable as women by and large and and
I don't think that I don't think that
the continuation of the feminist crusade
is doing us any favors it's very well
put now we've had several people to talk
about it on the show and we probably
we're not as articulate as you--as
batter when we probably haven't thought
about it as carefully as you have but
this is the reason we started
trigonometry is that we saw that all
these conversations that are crucial to
the time that we live in into the future
of our society when not being had in the
public media and that's why we started
the show and that's why we're grateful
for people like you to come on in and
tell us your views and others that we've
had we've got time for one last question
for us well the last question is what is
the thing that we're not talking about
but we really should be talking about
right well I've given that some thought
and I think that what we should be
thinking about and we're not thinking
about is not talking about
enough is the place of God in society so
it is my belief and it's a firm belief
of mind that a belief in God
from a belief in God flew the things
that a good society needs we need an
objective morality which restrains us
all from doing things which they we want
to do them are not good for us and what
I think is required is the humility and
it needs humility you need humility to
recognize and accept the belief that the
existence of God scientism the belief
that science solves all and that science
is in some ways our replacement for God
will lead us eventually down terrible
blind La La's and we need to we need to
rediscover our sense of our own
insignificance and ignorance we have to
understand that we don't understand and
we never will understand there are
mysteries beyond human comprehension I
think and the pretense that in some way
we do fine without God is a huge mistake
so that's what I think we should talk
about and I think that one of the things
which is which is tearing the country
apart at the moment is the lack of any
unifying belief system we've got an
elite which believes in nothing beyond
what is concrete and human and
materialistic and that ignores the
experience the entire experience of
humankind from it's very beginning you
know it's striking you go to I recently
went to Mexico and I saw these huge
strange Mayan temples out in the middle
of the jungle and I've never been before
more and I know very little about Mayan
culture
but the strange thing is that everywhere
you go in the world as you see the
ancient structures not redeem for
instance you know all these things are
built to the glory of God's plural they
all they're all an expression of human
belief in God and actually I don't think
we can do without that I don't think
that I mean we think we can do without
it and atheists are very trippy and sort
of cocky about it you know we've done
with all that crap you know we don't
need that rubbish and you know that's
not true
and because in the end the truth of the
matter is that that God does exist and
he is a reality or she is a reality to
billions of people in the world and
that's what a humanist and and the
secular don't really take into account
it's an interesting point because
Francis and I are both non-believers but
I hear a lot of what you're saying
because I see the effects of our loss of
God we had Douglas Mary on the show
recently and this is one of the things
that he said he said look I'm a
non-believer but I recognize that we
need something higher than us in order
to keep us and our worst impulses in
check and I also think that whether it's
a belief in God or maybe just an or some
kind of maybe secular I I don't know but
there's something that comes with the
the place where you pray there is a
community something that binds you not
only in a broader sense as a society but
also binds you to your nearby community
that human beings absolutely need and
without which we struggle and we wither
away and our mental health is affected
and I I'm a non-believer but III see
that I I can't ignore that you know it's
very it's very interesting that
that I would expect both of you to be
normal leaves because that is how
society is especially in a young Blake's
like you well educated very aware of the
world it's actually being announcing
yourself as a believer is actually a
tricky thing to do and it takes a bit of
courage to do it but it's strange that
when you see people for instance why do
people go to art galleries like you get
all these people who flocked into to
take modern personally I think it's aw
it's just so many warehouse junk as far
as I can see but but people stand in
front but if you go to a true work of
art a great work of art do you see
people standing there and there is
something numinous and beyond them
because they are they are awed being in
the presence of something they don't
know what it is and I can't put it into
words because you can't put this thing
into words but it's a feeling that there
is something greater than us right and
that to me is like a sort of vestigial
religious belief it's the same instinct
seeking an explanation for why it is why
things are as they are
you stand in front of something you
think wow this is [ __ ] incredible in
it and it's sort of beyond human in some
sort of way and that is as I say it it's
the same it's the it Springs from the
same the same part of the human
experience the same part of the human
consciousness where religion comes from
and it's it's it's about recognizing and
developing that ability in ourselves to
see to see to to to come to grips with
and try to understand what this thing is
that's where God comes for all that you
know and it's um it's something which
which is a society I think we we need to
rediscover and because I think that the
the headlong you know um the the things
which we've put
in the place of religion
satisfactory naked attraction for
instance trash culture absolutely and
what a wonderful way to end the
interview so Robin thank you so much if
people want to follow you on twitter on
social media you use it if you use it no
I didn't think you do but do by Robins
book the noble liar it's a brilliant
brilliant book and I'll see you write
another one as well yeah well well that
was that was the yes I mean no get the
latest one alright forget that one even
Robin doesn't want to sell that one get
the novel AIDS brilliant both in Francis
and I read it and thought there were
some really good points and they enjoyed
it as always follow us on all the social
media if you're not yet a patron of the
show this is your opportunity you can
get one of these mugs if you give a
certain amount and in general if you
believe in what we're doing and want to
support us please do that and as always
Francis always says this and it is
really important every week every single
week we get notifications of YouTube
unsubscribing people from the channel
and then you having Teresa bribe if that
is happening keep telling us because we
well we won't get anything out of them
but at least we can feel like victims
and you've also forgot one thing
Constantine you know what the thing is
Constantine is doing an Edinburgh show
oh yes how can i yeah you need to come
on yeah promote your Edinburgh shot ok
he's shy bless him he's been in England
too long go and watch it it's gonna be
great it is on at what time is it 7:00
p.m. and they'll give them balloon for
the whole of August it's called oh well
that ends well if you go to my Twitter
it's the pinned Twitter you can see a
little trail of what the show is going
to be about and I'm doing two shows at
the Bill Murray in August so come along
for there it's called a mixed race white
bloke I will be and I'll pin or
something there so come along and say
hello but guys thank you so much please
spread the word share it tweet it we've
we always get tagged and we see you
showing it with sharing what we do and
we're really grateful so thank you so
much
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
we'll see you next week bye bye bye
[Music]
there is the form that you were asked to
I said by signing this contract this is
a UNICEF on campus SOAs right he was
asked to sign an agreement that his
routine would not contain racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia
biphobia transphobia xenophobia
Islamophobia anti religion nante atheism
I think you're doing some quite
complicated mental arithmetic to offset
the people didn't think you were funny
you have absolutely no sense of humor
you feel like you're just I mean you're
just so fing a bevin outright you know
all right now that we got there in the
end you did do the good thing about
people the magic needed right as i now
got in each one of them is i haven't got
any racist sexist homophobic jokes have
been a student of university where you
can't make any joke about anything if
these poor little local students get
upset triggered
get over yourselves it's not about
comedy it's about ordinary people up and
down the country in here in britain and
in america feeling like they can't say
what they think I really got I get it I
get it especially especially the women
who want to become anyone Gareth Bale
right when from talking to Real Madrid
the guy left a perfectly good club for
more money everybody feels like we're
we're all kind of under arrest we're all
everything we say can and will be used
against us in the court of public
opinion and they're coming for the
comedian's first because we're we're the
ones that is you say are allowed to
transgress
but everybody else feels it and that's
why the stories got the rest on them so
it has
you
[Music]